ici la parole est à monsieur philippe
dit elle le président mes chers
collègues la question laquelle j'associe
mes collègues bernard deflesselles et
guy teissier
ça va être ça monsieur le premier
ministre et j'attends de vous monsieur
le premier ministre
une réponse plus sérieuse que celle que
jean marie le guen vient de faire un
michel vauzelle
car oui c'est un véritable arsenal de
guerre qui a été dérobé sur la zone de
regroupement et d'attentes de miramas
nous partons des matériels et munitions
pour les opérations extérieures
après avoir méticuleusement couper les
deux grillages entourant le site les
criminels se sont emparés sans aucune
difficulté
276 détonateurs ainsi qu'une dizaine de
pains de plastique et une quarantaine de
grenade
monsieur le premier ministre cet
événement très grave et très inquiétant
alarme au plus haut point nos
compatriotes
depuis les attentats du mois de janvier
le dispositif du plan vigipirate est à
son maximum
l'opération en sentinelle en place
depuis le 7 janvier mobilise toujours
plus de 6000 femmes et hommes qui ont
été déployés pour protéger 830 sites
identifiés comme sensibles par ce qui
concerne les cibles des sites sensibles
désormais leur protection a été
renforcée dans le cadre du plan cuirasse
ce dispositif comporte un doublement des
patrouilles la présence de maître chien
et le renforcement de la
vidéosurveillance qui étonnamment était
totalement absente à miramas force est
de constater que ce dispositif a subi
une percée inattendue grave et
inquiétante comme le qualifie un haut
gradé du renseignement dans l'attenté
des résultats de l'évaluation sous
quinzaine
des mesures de sécurisation de
l'ensemble des sites militaires
le stockage de munitions qui a commandé
monsieur le ministre la défense
pouvez vous nous expliquer monsieur le
premier ministre comment dans un
contexte de risque terroriste
simone est il possible d'avoir accès
aussi facilement à des des prix
munitions sur un site théoriquement
hautement protégé
merci la palette à monsieur jean marie
le guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président g et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vittel tout d'abord
je veux vous le dire que le gouvernement
partage tout à fait la gravité de
l'analyse que vous avez proposé vous
avez décrit la situation telle qu'elle
est et après avoir rappelé que jean yves
le drian est aujourd'hui et non en train
de défendre la loi de graal mation
militaire vous savez et vous avez décrit
vous même
d'ailleurs après les et les événements
tragiques que nous avons connue ces
derniers mois en france qu'elles ont été
la réponse du gouvernement et comment il
a mis en place ilan est en place avec
beaucoup de sérieux et beaucoup de
détermination les mesures de protection
de landre des français est également
évidemment des sites militaires vous
avez signalé et vous avez sans doute
peut-être des informations sur les
dysfonctionnements qui aurait pu avoir
lieu en l'occurrence à miramas pourquoi
le gouvernement a demandé non seulement
et a sollicité évidemment une enquête de
police et une enquête judiciaire
mais également une enquête
administrative ainsi qu'une enquête sur
site ainsi qu'une enquête beaucoup plus
générale des services de protection
désarmé en chine ce type de sujet nous
avons donc pris toutes les mesures de
renforcement de la sécurité des sites
existants et nous sommes totalement
mobilisés pour trouver toutes les
explications et prendre toutes les
mesures qui s'imposent face à cette
situation
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur